I want to talk about your bowtie I
haven't had a guess wear a bowtie I not
see I don't think since Louis Farrakhan
was on this is a penalty it's something
you don't see often but I have to say
you're pulling it off you look quite
sporty thank you really
yes you do thank you it's a new yeah you
know it came to me my my girlfriend
actually Emily Livingston she's if she
got how you tell a secret you know you
don't do this into a TV camera I'll tell
you something but don't tell anybody
let's see but when your hands up I don't
know what you're saying but I'm on the
right side a little different Andy I see
your girlfriend can see you yes she
introduced it hon how did it come up
what just a few days ago she said how
about a bowtie
why does she talk that way is she in her
late 90s
bless your heart yeah she's she has many
voice less your heart just means F you
yeah that's how they said that's how
they said f you in like 1904 yeah bless
your heart
that's not true I mean it I mean in the
best way I didn't bless your heart
so she recommended me she's about to go
on tour with Cher did I tell you that no
Cher's going on tour Cher's going on -
I'm going on tour multi-city tour and
she's one of the dancers a little troupe
of dancers you know in the songs and she
does Ariel and contortion uh you know
yeah okay so I think some of these
people that she's been hanging out with
wear bow ties yes and so she said you
should try it now is that a clip-on or
is it the real deal oh it's the real
deal how long does it take you to tie it
I used to know how very oh this is gonna
be fascinating I used to know how to tie
it like 20 years ago in some formal so
and then I forgot right uh and then the
guy at who sold it to me this is just a
few days old this was in the store a few
days ago showed me how to do it right
Emily learned first and she stood in the
store in front of me and breathed her
sweet breath on my face and tied my tie
Sheila and then become erotic I mean
every dirty Rotter is very erotic
yes um and then since she took off this
morning for the tour I was like you know
I got a I want to wear it on the Conan
and set Conan yeah and so I thought the
kids are talking about they love going
on the Conan yeah I'm going on the Conan
and I've got my bowtie yeah what do you
think Oh
you